the science is clear
that we need to act now to halve
emissions by 2030 and keep 1.5 degrees
within reach there are no compelling
excuses for our procrastination
not only have we acknowledged the
problem we're already seeing first hand
the devastation climate change causes
from heat waves and droughts
to wildfires and hurricanes and unlike
many other global challenges the
solution
to climate change is clear
it lies in consigning dirty fossil fuels
like coal to history
in ditching gas-guzzling modes of
transport
and recognizing the role that nature
plays in preserving life on this planet
and harnessing the power of nature
through renewable energy rather than
orchestrating its destruction
if we don't act now
the paris agreement will be looked at
in the future not as the moment humanity
opened its eyes
to the problem
but the moment we flinched
and turned away
we've seen some progress in the last few
days and weeks saudi arabia australia
and russia have all made net zero
commitments meaning 80 percent of the
global economy will wipe out its
contribution to climate change by the
middle of the century up from 30 percent
thanks to the uk's cop 26 leadership
countries such as the united states have
doubled their spending on climate aid
every nation this weekend summit will
end the financial support for
international unabated coal projects by
the end of this year
but these commitments welcome as they
are
are drops in a rapidly warming ocean
when we consider the challenge we've all
admitted is ahead of us
just 12
g20 members have committed to reach net
zero by 2050 or earlier
barely half of us have submitted
improved plans for how we will cut
carbon emissions since the paris summit
in 2015. and we've also failed to meet
our commitments to provide 100 billion
dollars a year to support developing
countries to grow in a clean and
sustainable way the un says emissions
will rise by 15
by 2030 and they need to halve
by then
the country's most responsible for
historic and present day emissions are
not yet doing their fair share of the
work
if we are going to prevent cop 26 from
being a failure then that must change
and
i must be clear
that if glasgow fails
then the whole thing fails
the paris agreement will have crumpled
at the first reckoning
the world's only
mechanism
viable mechanism for dealing with
climate change will be held beneath the
water line
right now the paris agreement and the
hope that came with it is just a piece
of paper we need to fill that piece of
paper to populate it with real progress
and i i know
that humanity has
in it the power to rise
to the challenge
the uk has proved it can be done we've
lowered our greenhouse gas emissions by
44 in the last 30 years whilst
increasing our gdp by 78 and we're
cutting our contribution to climate
change more and more every day
we've made some progress
of this g20 we've had a reasonable
g20
but there is a huge way still to go
we all know
that we have the technology
what we need to do now
is to raise the finance but above all we
need the political will in glasgow to
make those commitments and to keep alive
the hope of restraining the growth in
our temperatures to 1.5 degree